laeticia hallyday est elle abandonnée de
tous et est devenu persona non grata est
ce le début de la fin pour est dense et
pose une question c'est de cette manière
un scandale encore parce qu'elle a dit
que johnny ne s'était jamais sentie très
américain très française lci erika et
sébastien farran c'est maintenant c'est
pas elle c'est la voix de son maître
croc manqué le paye assez cher pour
qu'ils lisent des bonnes choses
donc finalement monsieur se sentait pas
du tout français sauf pour prendre notre
tune dessine elle se sentait très
américain ça a énervé laura smet bref
est ce le début de la fin ou la fin du
début regarde voyage
la semaine dernière au tribunal de
nanterre on s'écharpe est pour savoir si
johnny était france aime l'amérique
est ce la justice française où la
justice américaine qui doit trancher la
guerre d'héritage qui oppose laetitia à
david et laura énorme bourde de l'avocat
de laetitia qui déclare que johnny
n'aimait pas la mentalité française
sympa pour les fans qui lui rend hommage
depuis plus d'un an des chats leur
asthme et répond aussitôt à laëtitia
pourquoi autant de bêtises sur fond de
tour eiffel
allusion directe à ce que disait la
veuve il y un an pile en épousant johnny
j'ai épousé la france ait épousé la tour
eiffel le revirement de laëtitia laisse
donc pantois autre humiliation pour la
veuve son meilleur ami et ex manager de
johnny sébastien farran s'est mariée
sont vraiment la prévenir un vrai coup
de couteau - nouveau coup son absence à
votre récent mariage difficile de
justifier ce que la presse décrit comme
une trahison
laëtitia aurait même appris le mariage
de son frère de coeur depuis los angeles
sur instagram et quand on demande à
l'intéressé s'il a un message la gêne
est presque palpable
un dernier message je pense très fort
entre l'héritage du chanteur qui lui
échappe semaine après semaine et des
amis qui comme par hasard s'éloigne
également seul soutien sur lequel elle
peut compter jade maman je t'aime plus
fort qu'à l'aller retour sur la lune
alors est-ce le début de la fin ou
l'éthicien pour le coup le début de la
fin
c'est la question qu'on s'est posée et
qu'on vous a posé également le début de
la fin il ya beaucoup de oui beaucoup de
noms alors oui mathieu alterman c'est le
début de la fin pour quoi j'ajouterai
même c'est la fin du début de la fin et
on rappelle que en mai normalement on
alla breve vraies décisions savoir si
oui ou non il était américain ou pas
pour cela avoir une fois pour toutes si
toulouse à eva aux états unis pour
laetitia pour résumer ou si ça reste
entre en fait la seule ambition de
laëtitia aujourd'hui c'est de récupérer
l'argent pour continuer à vivre sans
travailler
finalement on sait que ça donc soit elle
gagne au niveau du droit
bon elle a perdu pour l'image soit le
père au niveau du droit alors toujours
perdu pour l'image c'est vrai parce que
c'est foutu
c'est ça va être très compliqué pour
elle de faire des séjours en france mais
dont vous avez raison donc maintenant il
mise tout avec l'avocat sur le côté le
droit et tant pis pour l'imam et cela on
y va à coup de johnny et américain sea
pourrait y ait un peu de thunes elle n'a
jamais pu saquer les français jamais ça
dans le sac
je pense que john innés mais peut-être
pas tant les français il aimait surtout
l'argent des français sur la face à
mathieu qui a écrit un bouquin sur
johnny et dieu sait si than cette
chanson et tout ça malheureusement
depuis qu'il est mort je suis moins faim
entre guillemets j'adore l'art ti je
suis moins fan de l'homme je pense comme
beaucoup de personnes
malheureusement on soulève trop de trop
de pierres alors non pour l'udc mais
c'est loin d'être foutu pour laetitia
parce que même si elle perd ce procès
déjà elle reste héritière parce que
c'est juste partager sa vie elle prend
tout mais elle aura comme une grosse pas
et quand on dit la halle est de plus en
plus seul sébastien farran l'a trahi
parce qu'il n'a pas invité au mariage ou
trop tard pour qu'elle vienne etc
c'est sûr qu'il faut qu'elle réinvente
par contre d'entourage est-ce que les
potes de son mari laissé sébastien
farran poupaud tout ça c'est des
musiciens nous imitent schiste et pour
la carrière du musical
ils vont pas rester à saint barth a dû
coller aux basques pour rien il faut
qu'elles se trouvent des nouveaux amis
tout ça donc c'est vrai qu'elle est un
peu seul en ce moment dans ma vie et
qu'elle a à quelle galère un peu
d'allant une seule est ce que c'est il
faut qu'elles se trouvent des nouvelles
à sa famille magali magail iqué projet
star à a surtout d'elle non non moi je
trouve que foie hgp arrêter de dire que
johnny il l est pas et français etc
je trouve que c'est faux et moi même si
des gens écrivent des torchons après et
maintenant qu'il n'est plus là bas moi
je les lis pas et ça m'intéresse pas et
moi j'ai toujours autant fan de lui et
de ses chansons elle maintenant je
trouve qu'elle est pas du tout finie
elle a toute la vie devant elle encore
juste de se reconstruire de la perte de
son mari
c'est tout ce que je lui souhaite
lalala light sensor j'adore mais ce que
tu me sors là c'est la vie de ces la
ville de hama c'est son avis et l'invite
à dijon côté d'or et qu'il y ait du mois
pour moi il est mais les français n'en
sais rien tu le foot beaucoup de bien
mais ça mais c'est messi qui est
fraîchement qu'un et dire ce que cet
homme pensait alors qu'il n'est pas au
total sur ce coup